hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible battle that lasted over well
not over but almost seven hours uh from
the round ten of the 2022 tata still
chess masters it's fitted versus
pragyananda and this game uh it has so
many turnarounds that um i don't know
first i thought i was going to have like
a one to two pause the video moments
then i realized i could have at least
15. now then i thought maybe not show
all the lines because the video will be
an hour long but um i i still decided to
show a fine portion of the line so this
might be a longer video uh if you are
not up to it you are welcome to check it
out uh at any time uh as this is uh this
is a very grueling game so that being
said uh let's check it out a lot at
stake here prague not having the
greatest tournament so far but he is the
the underdog here so of course um
no one is expecting him to win the
tournament
but uh he would definitely enjoy
uh uh well uh half a point at least uh
and david is doing uh incredibly well in
the tournament uh a full point will
propel him uh straight into second place
tied with anishigiri uh and then he will
be of course uh trying to catch up to
magnus carlsen as avid in the next round
place against magnus so we'll see what
happens
with it with the white pieces opens with
d4 yeah we have knight to f6 c4 we have
e6 knight to c3 and now bishop to b4 now
i was already very happy here as i'm a
great fan of the nimzo indian defense we
have queen to c2 uh this is the popular
choice nowadays after the bishop
captures you will be able to capture
with the queen uh we have castles by
black and now a3 we challenge the bishop
here bishop characters queen captures
and now striking in the center with d5
uh bishop to g5 are now attacking the
knight so the knight cannot move the
queen is on the eighth uh and now uh uh
prague goes for the very aggressive c5
also popular is just the captures on c4
as then after queen captures you get to
play b6 kind of with tempo the bishop
can be developed to a6 the b7 uh all
depending on what white plays so instead
after bishop g5 we have c5 here by
prague
and now d captures on c5 and d4 now so
prague repeats what he already played in
this tournament against rihar rapport uh
the only difference is uh rapper played
queen to g3 yeah but here with it plays
queen to f3 so that's the difference
from this one
we have knight beat the d7 continuing
development and now e3 uh just uh
challenging the d4 pawn and also
inviting uh black to capture here but
prague knows his stuff very well here
the absolute strongest move by the
engine is h6 this is what prague will
play so he came very well prepared
and now bishop captures on h6 the
problem is any move other than bishop
captures on f6 will be insufficient if
you for example go bishop to h4
we're going to play e5 and now after
let's see capture c captures queen side
castles as white is castling queenside
this game uh there's g5 and after the
bishop moves knight captures and c5 and
black's position is just uh well
even overwhelming
so instead after h6 we have the bishop
captures on f6 forcing black to waste to
move on recapturing knight captures on
f6 and now we castle queen side so now
for the moment our c5 pawn survives uh
we have e5 and now knight to e2 putting
more pressure on the d for pawn and the
position is a known one uh for example
magnus carlsen had this against lavon
ariana in the magnus cross an
invitational last year and magnus won
the game very nicely uh but in that game
aryan played
the g4 but here we have d3 and this is a
a very very tricky move but uh luckily
not for vidit already had this position
against um surah shakar ganguly in 2018
and i'm pretty sure both of them know
this so it's uh interesting to see who
who who prepared it better so knights to
see three by virid everything the same
as he played in his 2018 game bishop to
g4 now attacking the queen and of course
the rook here so it seems like black
already won the game but there is the
tricky rook captures on d3 now uh
attacking black's queen so queen to a5
and now comes queen to g3 getting the
queen out of harm's way queen captures
on c5
and now in the game against ganguly in
2018 vedic played e4 uh and he was able
to win that game but here he plays rook
to d2 and it's interesting that rook to
d2 the engine um prefers a little bit
more than than e4 so that it also
improved on his game from 2018 uh uh
meaning that of course he analyzes all
of the games even those that he won
because that's what you have to do if
you want to you know b at the very top
so here
and like i said uh rook to d2 is a new
move so as of move 17 we have a
completely new game so here bishop back
to e6
uh and now as the the pawn here is
attacked how do you defend it you can't
really play b three the a three pawn
falls so here uh vidit finds a very nice
move and that is of course pawn to b4
this is a great move in any position
pretty much so yeah here it works just
wonders uh and the thing is uh where do
you move the queen the e5 pawn is
hanging if you play queen c7 to defend
it then you basically invite knight b5
you cover these squares queen b8 knight
to d6 uh and next we're going to capture
the pawn so it's really not all that all
that much for black so instead after b4
we have the immediate queen to c8 that
doesn't matter white can have the pawn
then we're going to capture on c4 our
queen still attacks it so queen captures
an e5 we have bishop captures on c4 and
now king to b2 uh we have a5 prague
starts an attack against david's king
and now b5 of course we do not want to
open up the the file for prague's rook
uh bishop captures on f1 rook captures
and now queen to c4 so we we use this
capture to remaneuver our queen to see
for which tempo
and we want to play a four queen to b3
check and uh this will be of course very
very good for black so here we have rook
to c1 getting the rook out of arms away
and now a4 going for this
queen to b3 idea not necessarily right
away it's uh it's a threat we don't have
to execute it right away of course uh
and here we have knight to b1 by vedic
and the knight here is an incredibly
powerful defending piece because it
defends uh
everything here at the a3 upon the the
c3 square however there was a very
interesting way of defending with queen
to e7 the idea behind it being that
queen to b4 is possible and then you you
don't have to worry about it all that
much if queen b3 check we can move king
a1 and now if rook f28 let's say attacks
the queen queen to b4 and once the queen
moves of course black will not want to
trade queens black is the one attacking
we can just play king b2 and everything
is perfectly fine here uh and on the
other hand after going to a7 you could
also start with rook f to c8 so it looks
very dangerous the knight can't move
because the rook would hang but now just
queen b4 and again if queen to e6 then
we play rook to d4 and white is white is
doing more than okay here for example
rook to c7 rook c the d1 now with the
idea of trading off a pair of rooks and
then white will definitely be better so
maybe uh a line that could have been
considered but okay knight to b1 by
vidit and now queen to b3 with check
king the a1
and it seems like white is really in
trouble but
all in all it's very hard for for black
to do something about this because the
knight is an excellent defender here so
rook eight to c8 uh attacking the rook
on c1 with it trades once captures
captures and now this is the position uh
where uh
both players have some 55 minutes on the
clock and vidit finds the absolute best
move and that is a queen to f5 going
after the rook here
and asking uh prague what do you play
here so uh for example you could play
something like uh rook to c1 but then
you get checkmated uh rook to d8 and the
queen covers the h7 square that's just
it so queen to f5 very important uh
re-maneuvering with tempo guarding the
h7 square so here queen to c4 prague
just guards the rook and now has a nice
queen rook battery on the c file and now
rook to d4 attacking progress queen we
have queen back to c7 uh interestingly
uh this is a rook to d4 is best for
white but it's also kind of a draw offer
uh if prague plays for example queen to
c1 uh then what do you play as there are
some very tricky ideas here uh for
example you could play rook captures on
a4 you could grab this spawn but then we
play king h8 and this is uh very
important for black now we can play
knight to g8 and we don't have to worry
about getting checkmated for example b6
rook to c to now now prago can threaten
checkmate and you don't have to worry
about any checks because knight to b8 so
rook to be for guarding checkmate and
now we would probably see a draw here
queen to d1 with the idea of queen to e2
followed by rook to a2 checkmate so
again rook a4 uh going after some nice
rook to a8 ideas and now of course we
would see something like queen c1 uh
rook b4 queen to e a queen to d1 and
rook to a4 so our repetition like this
one is possible but also after queen to
c1 rook to d1 is possible just uh
attacking the queen because we want to
pick up this rook
and now queen back to c4 we play rook to
d4 and we get pretty much the the the
same thing rook to c1 uh queen queen c1
would be one queen c4 and rook to d4 so
this is uh although although the best
move it's uh it's an instant draw so
here prague plays queen to c7 he wants
to keep chances alive and now
vidit has a great opportunity but it's
not an easy move to spot he has to start
with g4
and this will
give him just enough time uh for for for
execution of g4 h4 g5 uh f4 and he will
be able to start pushing and once that
happens then he can even trade off some
material because he will be uh very much
ahead for example if if g4 let's say
queen to c1 now now it's a little bit
different now we can play rook captures
here but now after king the h8 there's
f4 and already those pawns are are going
after the black king rook to c2 we can
play rook to a8 check knight the g8 and
now even queen to e5 we guarded this
square
and we don't really care uh the h2 pawn
is free for grabs of course but then we
play queen to c3 we offer a queen trade
and we enjoy a very nice position as the
b7 one is very weak we can start pushing
our past a pawn so or rather soon to be
past a pawn and it should be very good
for vedic but he played the g3
sort of a safety move and also not
allowing queen captures on h2 and now
prague plays b6 uh we have rook captures
on a4 by vidit and now comes the knight
to d7 so probably in a
very tough situation but he finds the
the only moves that uh keep him in the
game uh and here we have rook to e4 by
bit rook the d4
is uh a little bit better because it
doesn't allow prague all that much
control play as the knight here would be
hanging however he played rook to e4
okay it's the same idea you you have a
rook to e8 if black rook ever leaves the
back ring but the disallows prague with
this very nasty g6 move because now you
don't have the thread of queen captures
on d7 so queen to f4 offering your queen
trade and now queen to c5
uh and here what do you play uh well the
b5 point is under attack so you have to
play rook to b4 that's one way to do it
or you could try with h4 give up the b5
phone play h5 and go for an attack so
those are basically your options however
vivid played queen captures on h6 and it
seems like okay maybe you can play this
we're threatening a lot of stuff here
maybe even just uh rook h4 uh followed
by queen to h8 checkmate but this is uh
a most poisonous pawn uh so
that that's going to be a problem for
vedic now prague plays a queen captures
on b5 and here a4 as the rook covers the
pawn
and now this is one of the moments where
i actually wanted to
uh use as a pause the video moment but
then after i've seen the entire game i i
just couldn't decide anymore so this
game we are skipping the pause the video
moment uh here there is only one good
move for prague
or rather one winning move for prague
and that is queen to c6 yeah it's very
important to play this
because it comes with tempo for one
we're attacking the rook here and also
we want to play queen to f6 check once
this check is delivered then the the
white king will not have it easy
against the rook the knight soon coming
into the game it's going to be
impossible to defend this so one thing
for example let's try queen h4 there are
many many ways to defend this for
example queen h4 regard the f6 square
and the rook not just knight to c5 and
after rook to b4 we have to play
something now we play b5 this is how we
break through uh and now it doesn't
matter what you play for example rook
captures on b5 we play rook a8 and there
is no defending this it's it's all over
now uh and another thing after rook that
b4 if you don't play b5 you could also
play rook to a8 right away but then the
problem is queen to c4 and white is
defending so that's kind of the idea as
uh you you keep an eye on the b5 square
and also you're pinning the knight the
knight cannot move
so that's the idea behind a queen to h4
but also rook h4 is possible threatening
checkmate but not just queen to f6 check
and there is no checkmate uh once the
rook blocks you have to do something
we're just going to play rook to c2 and
there's not all that much for for white
to try if rookie if knight a3 rook
captures on f2 white is completely
busted here so after queen to c6 we have
queen to f4 this is how he defends the
rook and the f6 square
and now knight to c5 the only winning
move by prague and not rook to c4
uh
not allowing this knight to move and
already they've burned so much time uh
vidin's uh with it has 11 minutes on the
clock prague has seven minutes on the
clock and prague needs to find rook to
a8 it's it's a deadly idea and we're
gonna discuss it a little bit uh because
prague missed it uh rook d8 is
incredibly strong as now you're
attacking this a4 pawn three times but
you don't really want to capture it you
want to push b5 and then it's all over
so black white would have to move the
king so b5
uh you know the a pawn will not be uh
pinned uh but we're still gonna just
play b5 and after eight captures we're
gonna play queen captures on b5 rook to
b4 and now this monster fork knights the
d3 check there's nothing you can do here
after king c3 of course we're just gonna
capture on b4 because our own queen is
still hanging so knight captures uh and
after queen captures we're gonna play
rook to c8 to check and this is a
terrible position for black
for white white will very soon get
checkmated so after rook the c4 this is
completely winning but prague plays rook
to d8 as i said they are very low on the
clock uh and then now we have rook to c2
by bit it now again rook to b4 is the
move you have to play because you really
have to keep an eye on this um a b5 pawn
and if rook to a8 then we go into that
exact same position uh where we said
that queen to c4 was guarding the
position you don't have b5 and you
cannot move the knight but okay after
rook v8 rook the c2 was played here uh
viridit wants to play rook a2 and put
the rook behind the the a pawn uh but
now prague goes queen to h1 and again
rook the a8 is completely crushing here
but it seems that this move somehow
eludes prague on every opportunity
so queen to h1 was played this is move
37 uh and prague has less than a minute
on the clock uh so no wonder that uh it
eluded him for so much but we we could
show it i mean with one minute on the
clock i said that this video might be a
little bit longer but the the variations
are really something um the idea behind
rook to a8 is not an easy one to spot
for example rook to a2 and now knight to
b3 with check king to b2 and these are
the only winning moves queen to c1 with
check king captures on b3 queen captures
on b1 rook b2 now queen d1 check king to
a3 and okay now the position is uh
much more winning now we strike with b5
of course the pawn now cannot capture so
you're gonna capture with the rook now
queen a1 check king to b3 queen to b1
check king to c3 and now of course rook
the c8 with check king the d2 rook the
c2 with check and now uh it is game over
king to d3 we're gonna play queen d1
check king to e4 and now rook the c for
check we pick up the queen and that's it
king e5 uh and rook captures on f4 and
you don't even have to worry about the
the a pawn because we're going to pick
it up he captures on f4 now queen a1
check and that's it um we force the king
to uh to another square queen captures
on a4 and now the position is winning
but there is so much to consider here
it's not an easy move to make with a
minute on the clock but okay prague went
queen to h1 uh
you you can just pick up the pawns which
is also very good for you but also you
are putting a lot of pressure on that
white king on the back rank so here
queen to b4
uh going after the b6 pawn and now just
knight captures on a4 also the trick is
that the queen here guards the square so
rook to a8
should be a problem for white
and it seems that the best for white is
maybe just to capture this knight uh and
then go go for this tricky end game
captures captures and then king to b2
now you have a rook and the knight
against the queen so maybe you will be
able to hold this uh however vivid
played rook to d2 he offered the rook
trade uh but now we have rook to c8 and
uh another uh move where prague misses
rook to a8 rook to e8 is again uh just
crushing here uh because after rook to
a2 there's again b5 and and you just
have no more moves uh there's nothing
you can do here uh
it's just a much better position for
prague because after queen captures
knight to c3 is just the deadly attacks
the rook uh the queen the knight of
cocaine the knight spin the knight
cannot move and it doesn't even matter
that you can capture the rook with check
because after queen captures now the
white king is in check and you lose the
queen on the next move king wherever
knight captures on b5 so
this this game is just uh uh is just
beautiful but okay probably went rook to
c8 for some reason prague just doesn't
see a rooked a8 on any uh point but uh
of course we have to remember it's only
moved 39 so prague was still extremely
low on the clock a few seconds on the
clock at best
and here we have queen to e7 uh so one
more move prague needs to make a queen
captures on a4 was still an idea here
just giving up the queen for for a rook
and the knight but here queen the e7 is
played and now finally under on move 40
for uh to reach time control uh prague
plays queen to a rook to a8 and now uh
sorry it's not rook to a8 uh if um uh
day eight uh uh
would be pretty pretty terrible he plays
queen to a8 uh and now uh he reached
time control and queen to e8 is is a
problem for vidit here uh because uh uh
you you can't really move the rook away
a rook to d8 would have been pretty
pretty serious for for white um so queen
to a8 is the only way to to try for
something uh if you play this rook to a8
move since i already mentioned it then
rooked the d8 check and after you
capture this uh
we're going to capture with check and
now after king h7 queen to h for check
and that's it king moves and you lose
the knight as well queen captures an a4
so everything nicely connects but
luckily prague will play the queen to a8
and now we have rook to a2 defen
attacking the knight and now b5
defending the knight
and now it's just a much much better
position for prague we have queen to b4
now uh but again queen to h1 asking what
do you play here uh b5 pawn can never be
captured because this knight the seat
remove is just too strong uh so here
rook to a3 was played keeping an eye on
that uh c3 square and now prague could
try a lot of different things but he
goes just for queen captures on h2 so he
grabs a pawn and he says that uh okay
very you've got nothing here and there
really isn't all that much for vidit
here he plays queen to the two he guards
the
uh the f2 pawn now comes queen to h5 and
now uh prague can play a whole lot of
stuff here he basically just wants to uh
centralize his queen improve the
activity um hopefully get grab hold of
this diagonal so uh vidiq needs to
decide whether he wants to prevent this
with f4 or something like queen to d4
he plays f4 and now queen to f5 so just
slowly improving the position queen to
d3 here that it offers a queen trade
maybe he can hold the end game but the
just queen f6 check queen to d4 and
queen to e7
uh again not not allowing this quick
transition into an end game
and now okay you could start with queen
e5 or for another queen trade but prague
would again again decline this so rook
to b3 here
but now just rook to a8 another uh very
nice idea finally uh rook the rook comes
to a8 and now everything is again
hanging there are so many so many
threats here so rook back to a3 and now
comes rook back to d8 prague refuses to
keep his rook on the a file uh here i
will show it because it's super
enjoyable b4 is just crushing that's it
if b4 is played the idea is after rook
to a2 we're going to play queen b7 and
now b3 is coming uh very nicely played
for example e4 knight to c3 completely
crushing rook captures queen captures
with check king to b2 now queen to 80
with check and after king to c1 we're
going to play queen captures and we want
your king to d2 and now queen to d1
check king to e3 and queen to e2 will be
checkmate so uh b4 regardless of whether
we play white or black b4 is always the
move so here rook to d8 was played
and now queen to e5 now offering a queen
trade and uh here that it offers uh
prague to double his pawns on the e file
and this time prague accepts this you
could also prolong with queen to b4 but
i i guess prague was um uh already tired
of repeating these queen offers so queen
captures f captures and now rook to e8
now he will go after the pawns here rook
to b3 going after the b5 pawn now rook
captures on e5 we have knight to the a3
again attacking the pawn and now knight
the c5 very nicely played by prague rook
captures on b5 and rook captures an a3
offering a knight for for this knight
and if you do this then it's not all
that much for example captures captures
with check and yes you are up one pawn
but you after the king moves you you're
gonna win another one and of course this
is completely winning you are you have
two points your opponent has zero pawns
so instead knights to c4 attacking the
rook we have rook to e1 check king the
b2 and the now knight to e4
going after the pawn here so now g4 at
this pawn is a bit its last chance to
hold the draw here rook the e to check
king to c1 and not knight to f2 going
after the pawn here we have g5 and now
comes king to g7 so now it's it's a
question how do you how do you win the
pawn uh do you have to win the pawn to
win the game or how do you proceed here
well
it it's definitely not simple uh here we
have knight to d2 uh
you have to hold it upon somehow because
the black will play something like
knight here rook here and
you're going to pick up the pawn and
interestingly if you try knight to d6
this doesn't work because we're going to
play rook e6 and the knight doesn't have
uh any good squares uh you you have to
be careful not to land anywhere
on this file then rook here attacks
uh the knight and well that's just game
over so we're gonna have to play knight
b7 and then knight h3 we go after the
pawn king d2 now rookie four and after
uh one more move he's made rook to g4
and then we just win this pawn and then
the game uh so that it played a much
better move knight to d2 uh so uh now
rook to e8 and now king to b2 uh we have
rooked the c8 cutting the king off from
advancing to the other side of the board
and now rook to d5 uh here knight the d1
check and now uh the thing is that
prague will play this perfectly and it
doesn't matter what video plays uh for
example if you play king to b3 then we
go rogue b8 check and now after king to
a3 we play knight to c3 we use the rook
as a tempo and then next move we play
knight to b1 check and we trade off our
knights rook d7 for example knight b1
check captures captures and now we've
transferred this into a rook and pawn
end game where the white king is
completely cut off and of course the two
pawns will be much much stronger either
you're going to win this pawn or you're
going to at some point play f5 um force
white to capture al paso and then you
will just advance your pass pawn to
victory because the white king will be
completely cut off so after knight d1 we
have kinked a3 instead uh also another
problem knight to e3 again it's the
pretty much the same thing only without
the check uh but um
interestingly prague doesn't play this
probably knight to e3 this also works
only from a different angle uh now we
have rook to d3 attacking the knight if
you try rook to d for to keep an eye on
the c4 square then we just play
knight to c2 and pick up the rook so
instead rook to d3 now comes knight to
c4 with check the knights get traded off
king b4 knight captures on d2 rook
captures and now rook to c1 and now this
is the end game that uh prague fought
for uh he has two pawns against the
viditz one g5 pawn uh can he win this we
have rook to a2 uh of course vedic will
always be able to defend this pawn uh so
how how can you do it uh the thing is
for example rook g1 rook to a5 and now
we now we have to play f5 and after g
captures king captures uh this is
winning for black but prague decides
that this could be much much trickier
and that maybe some tricks could exist
here so prague says i'm not even giving
you that one pawn i'm gonna win the g5
pawn and then i'm gonna just win the end
game straight up so here king g8 prague
does something amazing here he plays
king g8 we have rooked the a8 check king
to h7 uh videz repeats rook to a2 and
the now came to g7 so prague performs a
triangulation here giving vidit a move
and asking now what do you play and it's
not all that simple if you make a silly
king move then we might play some like
rook to g1 if you go up the board with
the king we play rook g1 you you can no
longer play rook to a5 to defend the
pawn so it's very very tricky so vedic
plays rook to a5 and only now king to f8
we have rook to a7 not allowing progress
king to enter the game now king to e8
again asking white what do you play here
again if you try advancing the king we
just play rook to g1 we attack
we attack the pawn so it's not easy if
you go back with the king we can deliver
a check and then you can't go to the a
file because check picks up the rook and
if you go the other way around we can
even play some like rook b5 and then we
go after the pawn this way so it's not
easy to keep an eye on this pawn rook to
a5 very defense it says you are not
touching the spawn now king d7 you can't
have everything now rook a6 cutting of
the king from the sixth rank now king e7
uh we have rook to a2 now comes king to
e6 rook to a5 again guarding this and
now finally rook to f1 here prague is
preparing rook to f5
and what can we do about this well uh
not all that much he plays rook a6 check
king e5 sorry king the e5 uh rook to a5
check here we have king to f4 and now uh
there is really nothing else you can do
here king to g4 and rook to f5 is coming
king to c3 was played now comes king to
g4 and it was in this position on move
79
that vidit resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so an
incredible incredible game by both of
them uh tough break for vidit as he was
hoping to win this one and go into or or
even a draw would mean a lot to him
because he would then go into
uh next round to face magnus carlsen and
with a chance of becoming the leader of
the tournament if he maybe wins the game
against magnus now it's
not going to i'm not going to be as
sweet and tomorrow is the rest day so
also with it is going with this tough
loss into into a rest day uh but here
you just resign because whatever you
play rook to d3 king rook here and now
the pawn is just lost it doesn't matter
what you do we're either uh trading off
the rooks uh and then the king captures
the pawn into a completely winning king
and pawn end game or if you play
something like chicken king captures
again it's completely winning
so uh really i i have no words for this
game it was so rich and so full of
everything and uh that it uh completely
out prepared prague here even though
prague prepared incredibly well
but uh probably just show uh has shown
great resilience and great uh innovation
you know in
in facing uh uh such difficulties and he
just uh came out on top uh time trouble
was there for both of them uh and it
just seems that uh you know on that
critical move for the prague fund that
queen to a8 move which uh
allowed him to to continue grinding with
some additional time so so i don't
forget uh here are the standings after
around 10 so magnus is leading the
tournament with seven points out of ten
in seoul lead uh geary with six and a
half out of ten if uh if very joined him
if it had won this game then he would
have joined geary uh then with six we
have mamadiarov and rapport uh with five
and a half yes penko karyakin invaded
with five fabiano caruana with four and
a half young sister of duda in jordan
fun forest uh with four sam shankland
daniel dubo uh and uh uh prague with
three and a half and in last place niels
garandalius with three out of ten
uh so
that's it for this game hope you guys
enjoyed it was a bit of a longer video
now now i see it's okay already almost
30 minutes so sorry about that but i
mean it's complete complete madness and
i i was very sad to see how many uh fans
that were were mad in the chat
that you know maybe prague should have
let vidit won because uh he kind of
ruined his tournament uh but i think
that's uh that's a terrible thing to say
this is a huge achievement for for young
prague and he will
cherish these moments for uh for for a
very long time i believe and i i don't
think um
it would be okay to you know manipulate
uh things like that
uh so yeah now once again uh thank you
all uh for uh staying this long i would
like to thank david kimura thomas earl
trevor furtado souza gwen guo khan and
william rose for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
spectacular event until it finishes so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day